I just heard your comment about
co-parenting and I know some people who
are co-parenting now or are kind of just
taking the parenting life as if it's
just ours easy that works out it works
out if it doesn't it doesn't you know
and that's not how the child sees it
I've seen I work with kids actually have
a speech therapist and I work with
children and I deal with those kids
every day where co-parenting just isn't
working out and it really isn't working
out for the child make sure you have a
strong foundation in that relationship
otherwise it is just it can be
detrimental for you yes but incredibly
detrimental for that child especially
because when we're baby's important to
this world the only thing we know is our
parents that's that's where we find out
what love is and if we don't see it from
the co-parenting then do we really know
what kind of lovely deserve or what kind
of love we should get onward field Gang
Gang Gang Gang sir appreciate that you
know that's a good that's a really
interesting thought yeah because if
you're just Co parents and you dig the
children now you could still show the
child some love the children will feel
loved from a male parent and a female
parent or but I mean or it could be you
know same-sex parents but I think I I
mean I feel like you you're gonna get
more of a full batch if you have that
male-female I mean that's you know it's
been the current it's been the recipe
it's been mother nature's recipe to have
the male-female but yeah it's like
you'll get that the kid will still get
the love from a parent a male parent and
a female parent but they won't get they
won't maybe see the example of love so
they might not see the parents love each
other they may not see there's like an
element that they could really miss
so yeah I don't really thought about
that exactly that if yeah if you live on
one Street and your kid lives yeah if
you live on one Street with your kid and
the dad lives across the street are down
the way and you guys are just kind of
you know back and forth it may feel kind
of dis this you know that it might not
be continuous parenting it may kind of
start and stop here and there and then
also kids might start to learn well love
is just love is just you know you get
love from one person from a mom or from
a dad and it's not a also something you
see so if they don't see the love
between the parents so then you the kid
might the kid could feel like that like
that that love isn't or isn't something
that's even in the world you know
because I've never seen an example of it
it's just I get a love for my mom here I
get love for my dad here but I don't see
an example of love between two people
that are you know like in a marriage or
two people like a man and a woman that
love each other then the kid might grow
up and not really feel an attraction
anybody they might be fully asexual they
may sexers so that's interesting you
know I appreciate you sharing that
thanks for calling in Sarah and look
once again thanks for you know sharing
that story two episodes ago about
dropping that HJ on your husband back in
a day while your dad was driving y'all
around manners I mean that that episode
really I think took us all to a
beautiful place in time that that you
can only exist in as a child you know
and as a first-time when you get that
first touch let's say let's take another
call that came in here here we go
today see oh this is Vivian from Los
Angeles hey Vivian from LA thank you for
calling in onward I was listening to
last week's episode and I thought I'd
share a story my mom and dad were really
young when they had me my mom was 19 and
my oh yeah that's beautiful if Dad was
couple years older
yes oh he trying to be wild like that
with the young ladies I've done it I
feel it onward come they never got
married for some time I was really young
and they lived apart from each other and
you know talk to me back and forth
between them but once I actually got
into elementary school they decided to
move in together and become roommates in
Chicago nothing or a man's hurt or
anything like that they just wanted you
know to co-parent together in the same
household and honestly it was my
favorite time of my childhood so yeah if
any single parents are considering
co-parenting in the same household I
could say from my experience it was
really really good for me and actually I
just kind of miss it but yeah JJ thank
you for calling in let me look up really
quick the definition of co-parenting
just so I'm operating on a clean
co-parenting share the duties of
parenting especially of a separated or
unmarried couple so basically it is
people co-parenting sometimes called
joint parenting or shared parenting is
the experience of raising children as a
single parent
when separation or divorce occurs
however placing the sole focus on your
children can be a great way of helping
to make co-parenting a positive
experience so it's where both where the
parents are single but they're both
raising the child so that could be in a
couple of ways where you know you guys
are you know just you guys are divorced
it could be that you guys are like this
situation roommates
so obviously it's it there is something
special that happens when as a child
then from your perception when when both
your parents are in the same place
and I and you know what I could really
imagine that it's like because with
parents you can play off well you can
play one off of the other it's fun to
see them interact you know they're like
this when you're a kid your parents are
like this weird comedy duo sometimes
it's just cruising around the house just
trying to take away your privileges so
it's really interesting to have I guess
to get to see them at the same time
interact with each other it could be
kind of lonesome if you just go to your
dad's house and he's just being you know
kind of sad or something we're looking
up escorts and are just being like a
nice guy or you go to your mom's house
and she's just kind of being sad or mind
he's crazy you know high-powered sexual
toys you know these real you know these
crotch you know damn John Deere is
making things for women's crotches now
and it is just good god I mean they got
some things that run on gas powered you
got a you know you got a ding you know
you got to float the choke a little bit
before you can even get that thing to
start up and so that's really I don't
know what kind of I don't know what's
going on so yeah I think seeing those
parents getting to see your parents kind
of give each other a wet willy or tickle
each other or two you know or try on
scarves or different things like that
there's gonna be something special there
having that moment where you're painting
you know maybe playing hide-and-go-seek
and both your parents are there to play
with you know there is something about
having them in the same house so now
maybe if your parents like you said your
parents just happen to live together
they weren't married but they lived in
the same house so maybe co-parenting is
more effective if the parents are living
in the same home even if they're not
married but they're there together at
the same time which I could imagine
because from what I hear there's a lot
of like something that happens with like
a nesting you know where it feels like
you're in a nest and a safe place where
you can grow you know your mom is there
to nurture you your father is there to
take care of and provide and it feels
probably very natural to us because a
lot of species do it you know you see
this show they got a thing called on
what is it penguin
I don't know Polar Express or something
maybe it's like about a bunch of
penguins it's on the nature show they
have a bunch of penguins and these month
dude these guys they're penguins I don't
know if you know penguins are they're
basically they're kind of they act like
kind of like little [__] I mean they
don't you know they kind of short with
people you know they always like just
you know they don't even really you know
they just sitting over there giving you
that uh who's that guy um that slumber
Jay arm what's your boy he was out he
could barely point at the oil John
McCain you know he got that low hitter
you know he just got that I mean it's
very very you know he got that half mast
baby you know and he you know
they that's how they raised their arm a
little penguins they don't do much the
guys all kind of huddle around and then
the women they get pissed and they've
jump off of a mountain and go get a
belly of fish and then they come back
one of them vomits into the child and
then the other one goes out but I think
as the child to see your parents just
doing that shift that you know that
teamwork that tandem you realize I bet
you learn a lot about you know what it
takes as a team as a tandem to make it
work you know my parents I remember my
dad liked to sleep in his car at the
park and he would sometimes drink too
much and he would just stay outside and
just sleep in his car in front of the
house and he used to have a lot of cups
of like different Mardi Gras to balloons
from the parade and uh and he would just
throw him out of his car when he was
driving like kind of like he was his own
little parade a little bit
I mean he was also 80 years old at this
point or set you know 78 or something
but but yes sometimes he would get a
little bit of free champagne because one
of his friends worked at the champagne
distillery and he would drive over old
champagne and my dad and I would sit out
on the porch sometimes and you know chug
down a half a bottle of old champagne
and I would be out there and he would
let me smell his breath because I like
the way that the the champagne smelled
but then I think it's just fun as a kid
to have both of the parents around it's
something real I mean Jesus I think just
you know I mean there's enough kids
already that are raised by single
parents it's just a little hectic it's
not the same vibe but maybe that's where
we're headed and if we are headed there
as a species because we're such in this
meat generation and you know myself and
and I'll you know a lot of us are
they're not even by choice it's like you
know social media really puts us in our
own world and our own perceptions and
you know we have our own Facebook page
we have our own I G we have our own
snapchats we have our own whatever it is
tick tocks or whatever it's all our own
personal things that it you know we
start to look at our as our lives as our
world just as ourselves it's just it's
just me it's just me so if that's where
we're headed as people then then then
co-parenting might be the only viable
possibility because if your parents
aren't gonna live together they're not
gonna stay married or they don't want to
be married
then at least if they can live together
in an environment where they can raise a
child so I don't know I'm thinking a lot
about that kind of stuff just today for
some reason [__] man I'm [__] tired
you ever sleep a lot and you're tired
you're like dang dude what was that
doing in my dream was running a lot or
something but thank you for calling in
you know maybe there'll be a
turn where people start to you know
really make good choices about
relationships and you see a lot more
kids getting raised in the nest and and
you see just you know you see more that
vibe a little bit but yeah that hockey
puck kind of style of child raised and I
don't know you know I've never done it
but I don't know what it's I don't know
if it's super healthy I don't know and
then sometimes you don't know sometimes
some kids is just made out of you know
fish and snails and puppy dog pails you
know or whatever you know cinnamon and
spice and nothing nice or whatever you
got a kid who's got [__] you know
made out of 70 grams a damn nutmeg in
his neck and he's never gonna get it
together
so some of that is just kind of God's
plan well my family was never really
close when when I was growing up so it's
kind of I feel like we've always almost
looked at each other as these separate
entities than we have as a group and
actually even to go back to the
co-parenting stuff you know I feel like
in some ways I've really struggled
become because of that you know I
remember only some my father kissed my
mother one time and it was on the top of
her head during it was her birthday and
she was pissed off about it kind of you
know and he just they'd be each been
having you know they'd had a little bit
of that champagne that God dropped some
often my dad always said he bought it
but you know him and the guy with him
fight about the prices at a champagne
and [__] on the porch and the [__] was
free so my dad like you're getting you
know we all notices you you know old
stale champagne so but anyway he brought
in a bottle for my mom's birthday and
then he kissed from the top of the head
and I just remember seeing my mom just
be disappointed and and I was already
such an aware kid I'm not saying that
that damaged me or changed my life or
anything you know I was already
predestined to have a level of I think
awareness as a child that I was going to
be highly sensitive but
you know but to go back to just a
previous like you know we my family
didn't build up those connections I
didn't really have an understanding of
relationships you know my father slept
on the couch always I never saw him a
mom I didn't even know that they had a
room together you know I didn't even
understand it so you know I think I
definitely picked up on that energy you
know I don't know if I could ever share
a room with a woman of you know he says
talk about that sometimes I ever got a
house or something I would have to get
maybe a different room for my wife or a
separate house and that sounds crazy man
but that's just you know I don't know me
and maybe I can defeat that over time
but man it just there's something that's
you know I don't know if I was out there
or not you know I remember on Christmas
I would go out there my dad would be on
the couch all the time and it was just
kind of weird and but I don't know as a
young man as a young kid if you go out
you know I remember feeling sorry for my
dad I felt bad for him
and I remember like my mom was in this
closed off space at the other end of the
house it wasn't really closed off but
there was like a couple doors you know
that usually at night I think we're
closed and so I could I could go knock
or someone but my dad was there he was
accessible he was on the couch and so so
I would you know end up seeing him and
he was kind of awkward and uncomfortable
maybe and also older and probably asleep
and smelling like champagne and and so
my mom always felt closed off to me she
felt far away I think when I was a kid
and my dad probably felt rejected or
emasculated or let down and those
energies I think do float around in the
air they float around in the air and
then landing a child so nothing ways we
don't know in places we don't know and
they land in a child and I look I'm just
kind of guesstimating trying to just go
through my own you know moan
history like searching my browser
history of my own brain and feelings but
but so we didn't have that connection is
what I'm saying we didn't have a lot of
those connections me my sister's you
know then I you know I my dad left and
then he passed away I went to live with
friends at 14 we never were always
separate entities so if they were to be
upset about things I think they probably
learned more about me through this and
sometimes I think the only reason I even
do this podcast is just kind of you know
in this real far-fetched circle is so
you know so maybe just so my mother will
Know Who I am a little bit or something
I don't know that might sound crazy but
so as sometimes I hope that she listens
you know but I don't know if she and I
are at the communication level where she
would ever you know she'll say sometimes
I saw some of your podcast or I saw a
clip but I don't know if she you know I
don't know I mean sometimes I feel like
I mean I've said it before that most of
my life is just a debt has been just a
desperate just just miss Elaine it just
errant and confused attempt to try and
connect with my mother probably and not
even an attempt that I'm always
conscious of sometimes an attempt that's
just
you know just like somebody throwing
just rocks you know like a lake at night
or something and they're also are into
the ocean and they're also sleepwalking
so they don't even know they're doing it
you know it's interesting when I really
I wish I could really had a good chart
of everything I've ever done in my life
or because I bet there's a lot of just
miscellaneous patterns that I've had
that have just been attempts to connect
[Music]
mother or with someone with a parent
with someone or with myself even maybe
you know I'm I'm not sure but sometimes
I wonder if Oh sometimes I wonder for
all of us what we do is just some
reflection or some inverse our behaviors
are just an inverse of
if our behaviors are just an inverse of
like unsettled
emotional debts that we have with our
parents are with our childhood or with
like if everything we do is just this
kind of mummy kind of like this zombie
walk to fill these couple little things
that were never filled you know these
couple needs is a child I don't know but
that's why I mean I do think as the
parenting is very important you know
because you're just gonna give the kid
the best shot so you can't have the kid
[__] uber in two hours to go meet the
other one I think that's a little tricky
there's just not ideal but then also
that's a lot of where we are these days
that's a lot of where we are but moving
forward we can do it difference so if
our parents were far away from each
other moving forward it's like well am i
able to be able to have an adult
conversation with this man or this woman
and say hey you know I know we have this
kid you know we disagree with you know
we're not in love but can we be can we
cohabitate or be in the same space or
close enough to each other where we can
have an effect on this kid's life easily
you know but just because it could be
something that's really gonna start
popping off or it could not be you know
we don't know which way the tide is
always going to go sometimes the moon
will get tricky and kind of do a
different pull on the water um Wow you
know it's crazy as my sister can't even
read but what does it have to do with us
right now hope you enjoyed that video
and you can watch another and you can
watch this one you can watch this one
different options different choices some
guy just brings you one option not this
guy two options watch one that's what I
guess fun